a woman who was waiting months for
unemployment benefits has a message for
others tonight she says when her back
pay finally came in
it was then stolen joe moller spoke
directly to her he's live with her story
and other unemployment information hi
joe
hey there brian yeah we've talked a lot
about how fraud is impacting dieter and
the entire system well we did speak to
one woman who says
she waited months to get her
unemployment benefits and when she got
that debit card that they all use and
had a negative balance on it
they said that the money was on one of
the cards and it had already been used
helen shannon says she has nowhere to
turn
i want to say it was like the end of
september i tried to use my card and i
should have got my deposit that day
and it wasn't working and then when i
went online it said negative
ten thousand something dollars those
thousands of dollars are from the back
pay she says she has been owed since the
spring
now her unemployment payments are simply
paying off the negative balance you can
see it go on there they just go
it goes from it went from a 10 000
balance to now it's like
8 000 something she tells us she
contacted both bank of america and
dieter
she says the bank told her they are
looking into it but meanwhile she is out
hundreds each week
when i talked to nevada unemployment
they said it's not their problem
fraud has been a problem facing the
unemployment department monday morning
we noticed a handful of people having
issues getting into their accounts
this new feature saying recaptcha on the
top of the login page is something that
is new
that many did not notice and were having
trouble logging in if you have an issue
make sure to look at that shannon says
she was grateful to be approved but is
struggling she has a message for others
to make sure they know where their cards
are
now um i do have like a lifelock
you know just so it alerts me anytime
we did reach out to bank of america
regarding her case and they say they are
going to be looking into it to see what
exactly the issue is there if you do
fall victim to
a fraud the first thing you should do
according to bank of america is to
contact them reporting live joe mohler 8
news now